welcome back to the GameSpot stage here
at e3 2016 joining myself and Justin
Herold is Alex Grondahl from dice here
to talk some battlefield 1 Alex how is
your show going
let's go great it's fun to finally get
to see the game in the players hands you
know this is what it's all about
and trying to get some time into reading
what they're writing about it and seeing
what we can do but it's what I'm walking
through and looking at them playing it
looks like they were having fun so that
makes me makes me excited we got to see
a lot of people play it did you get to
meet Snoop Dogg although I didn't
actually I sat behind the stage trying
to make that broadcast I was actually
helping out trying to find a good
gameplay moments so we could cut between
so I actually I did so that that kind of
describes what I do my dates are never
the same I go sometimes talk to you guys
sometimes I act like I'm some sort of
team producer other days I'm yeah so
that's what a producer does I guess and
just goes around and do random stuff
helps keep everyone in line so you guys
announced the game a few weeks ago now
had a fantastic reception he's showing
off more at e3 what do you think is you
know the key bit that you really wanted
to shout about so this is bringing you
know multiplayer to the show floor
that's what we're kind of showing we're
bringing a couple of new things to
multiplayer that we haven't show before
so first of all we are showing the
dynamic weather so what that means is
that as you are playing the weather
conditions are changing on you and that
forces you a little bit to adopt the new
conditions if you're a clear daylight
and sun is shining you know clearly you
can see people coming from 4 miles but
if you know the rain comes same or even
it changes to a fog you really need to
kind of move a lot closer to see people
and that kind of changes the way that
you play the game it's a part of what we
you know we call the dynamic sandbox
it's like an element that we haven't
talked about there of the additional
battlefield elements and it's it's quite
cool to see people react to it and you
know as you see the silhouettes in the
fog you kind of like has he seen me can
I sneak around them and stuff like that
what's been incredibly interesting about
the battlefield 1 reveal is that you
guys are going back in
so at present you know the its in its
popular to be like a modern even
futuristic first-person shooter why did
you guys decide to go back in time we
didn't that wasn't actually the decision
we've started out with an idea that we
wanted to do a little bit different we
wouldn't make a new game that challenged
ourselves and our players a little bit
so so that was kind of did that the core
of the idea and there was a couple of
people in the studio that have been
wanting to make a battlefield world war
one game for quite some time so they
pitched this to us and it just clicked
it just clicked because that much
exactly what I thought we needed to do
new gameplay experiences and challenge
ourselves a little bit so we didn't you
know decide to go back in time it was
just like there was the right idea that
happened to be at the right time and
these two needs kind of met each other
so while thinking of new gameplay
experiences were pitch meetings like
well what if we did a battlefield kart
racer we did battlefield fighting game
yeah no I don't think we got that crazy
when our picture we know always I want
to make a battlefield game in this
course oh so here we most pictures there
art might actually have been a couple of
those racing would work really well in
battlefield yeah actually when you talk
about it there was actually talks about
you know some sort of pinball game
battlefield pinball game back in the
days I seem to have some vague memories
of that now that you mention it I have
to figure out what happens with that
sounds kind of wine there's no it's fine
yes games like Battlefield pinball
mobile yep you know what I find
interesting is that everyone kind of
assumed that like the weaponry wouldn't
be as advanced as you know we're used to
now but people that's a big
misconception because back in World War
one we had all these incredibly had
tanks you had rifles yet automatic
rifles semi-automatic all this kind of
stuff what was it like sort of going
back and using those kind of weapons
compared to the really modern ones so
what I find the most interesting about
these weapons is that they are more
unique in the way that they look in the
way that they play so we can we can pull
weapons apart a little bit so so in many
model games it's like weapons are kind
of
feel and play very similarly when
assault rifle feels like a carbine and
it feels like in this empty I mean the
overlap is quite big so what I think is
cool here is that you can really pull
them apart and really create this weapon
works exactly like that so it's quite
short fast fire you have another one
that is slightly different and so I
think that's actually adds more variety
to to the game in total and and what I
actually think is really cool is that
you have probably never played with
these weapons before this is the first
game that you're playing so it's not
another m16 that you probably shot a
billion times you actually have
completely new weapons to play around
with and hopefully people feel that well
we're was there a lot of pushback at the
beginning when you guys were like let's
do World War 1 and they're like no now
World War 2 we have to you have to do
World War 2 or before but what was the
moment when they were like just my word
this might be a good idea I think it was
a gradual change but it was a couple of
watershed moments that we've had so we
made multiplayer demo quite early so so
you kind of proved that we could do
multiplayer and people were like yeah
good this is good
that's also kind of what we are good at
producing multiplayer and and then we
actually made a demo for our campaign
I'm a shoulder to the company not not a
very long time ago and and that had a
profound impact I think on the people
who watch this that basically felt like
everyone was on board with that idea
that it really kind of changed it and
but I think I think yeah you know I
think all having something in a
PowerPoint or whatever the type of
presentation doesn't really have an
impact it's always when you make a game
and you actually show live software
that's when it's actually being felt so
added yeah do you guys go for more
authenticity with those feelings or is
it trying to create something that feels
unique and different like so so we we
want to make a game that it's fun first
obviously that's always the case let me
do this but the cool thing is that all
the stuff that you see here and in the
trailer are and that you'll be playing
with in the game are inspired by the
real world counterparts and events that
have taken place so it's authentic and
it's in its in that sense but we do have
to take some creative liberties every
now and then
to cater for the more and created a
little bit more fun experience I was
gonna say I mean back in World War one
there were always the stories of them
you know the Battle of the Somme they
were saying that one in every three
shells would explode is you can a factor
in those kind of you know like tanks
breaking down in the middle of the
battlefield you're gonna have that kind
of authenticity or so yes in certain
elements of the game there will be
things that are representative of what
you just described
but in multiplayer in general we don't
really want to create that randomness I
don't think people like too much
randomness when it comes down to firing
things exactly that hasn't really been
we actually tested it in the past it
doesn't doesn't feel right I mean yeah
it would suck yeah so and I also think
that what what I would want the players
to feel like so when these weapons were
actually created back in and World War
one this word this word kind of
top-of-the-line stuff those were the
most well engineered stuff they have had
the access to and so so when people
actually started using that that that is
like that is modern to them yeah to the
people who were using them how I think
we're trying to capture a little bit of
that as well in the in the game so they
should never feel rattly they shouldn't
feel like clunky and and breaking down
all the time they should feel like
they're modern innocence did you ever
manage to be able to go out and shoot
some of these guns themselves I mean how
did you record the the sound effects for
the guns as well yeah so so we have been
looking all around the world
to try to find these weapons and they're
not super common people don't have them
laying around but we found some people
in the US and even in Sweden where we do
our work and we sent our audio guys out
and recorded a lot of it and for those
we couldn't record many of these weapons
they are basically early versions of
weapons used in world war ii which is a
much more common to find so it basically
the the gun nut guy he'd basically go
they only change the bolt a little bit
so it should sound exactly the same
now actually they always change the
frame over here so it should be a good
analogy to that so so I think that we
found pretty much all the source
material we needed and also want out and
record it and it's actually every time
they go out they put together these
awesome videos
for us in the team and show when they
shoot all these weapons and it's it's
pretty crazy
it looks pretty wild in the blimps are
just such a crazy addition to the game
oh of course that was you know part of
the world back then but was there any
trepidation when you're like blimp is a
bad idea
no that was then it must have an airship
that was kind of like yep that is going
on that is going directly and so we knew
quite early we wanted to have these
behemoths in the game because there we
felt like we can bring some really cool
opportunities in there so the airship is
one and it's fully player controlled you
can kind of pilot it around all around
the map and drop bombs and shoot various
types of cannons and fight against the
biplanes that are trying to take you
down when it crashes so like I've seen
it crash in the in the trailers and it
always seems to crash on on the city or
the town can it crash someplace else
yes absolutely so I think that most
people reason that you see in the crash
over the city is because that is
worthless that's where most of the
people were yeah if you're dropping
bombs you want to drop it on top of the
people that was right there but it no it
can crash pretty much anywhere depending
on where you are obviously so it it's
it's a completely dynamic and player
driven from that point to be where it
actually collapses terms of the
single-player campaign there's different
viewpoints that you can take which which
nations are gonna be represented in
those so in the campaign you'll be
playing along multiple different
factions the crew that you saw in the
trailer that I saw that is one of them I
this is a British crew I'm gonna reveal
that to you because they are in the
mark-5
which wasn't it recognized those acts
yeah and you did recognize those accents
so yes so you'll be fighting alongside
and experiencing alongside multiple
different factions in this in our
campaign because we have several
different stories those guys are one
story we have another one that you might
have seen in the previous trailer which
is it's the woman riding the horse she's
not the character that you also be
playing as which is a completely
separate story so it so again there's
multiple different characters you miss
Paris playing and there's multiple
different stories in multiple different
locations and then it provides again I
can say multiple in one more time
it provides more perspective from
several different places around the
world which i think is quite interesting
is it gonna follow the wall in its
entirety or just from a certain point to
the end so basically these are stories
that take place during the war in
various different phases of the war but
it's not going to follow the war in in
in a kind of sequence or a commercial
battle because it's it's about the
stories that these characters have with
each other not necessarily about save
the world story these are stories about
you and I in the tank trying to figure
out where to go next and that's the the
personal stories we should think is a
little bit more interesting to
experience yeah and it's so hard to tell
the story of World War 1 it was such a
complicated war to get like historical
absolutely guys research that a lot yes
we did and we don't want to even go
close to try to explain because I think
I still think historians today argue
over exactly what happened in and if we
if I don't want to jump into that debate
that's that's for historians to do and
for us as game makers but we will be
using the the events that took place as
a backdrop obviously and the actual
events that took place so that's I'm
gonna leave it at that I think what's
kind of like been the thing you've been
most excited to work on in this project
what's kind of really piqued your
interest so first of all I'm excited to
work with the team that I'm working with
I always that's the thing that keeps me
motivated every day to come into work to
see these amazing people that that pull
off some pretty amazing stuff and and
that we together can can work and
basically create what you see here today
and the reactions to that as we see from
it that is hugely motivating I have a
fantastic team behind me working on this
but if I talk about the game just for a
second what I'm mostly excited about
there is is there was a moment here the
other day where I am playing the game
and me I'm as a producer I only see the
problems with again but for a minute
there I got completely absorbed by
playing the multiplayer I was in it and
that doesn't happen too often for me and
and I got this some sort of old 94 two
wives going in there as well and I that
was that was yeah quite the for that
wonderful Alex thank you so much for
joining us when can we be playing
battlefield so we will be having an open
beta later this summer so if you go to
battlefield , become an Insider you get
to know first when that thing is
available battlefield one will be
launching worldwide on October 21st
awesome thank you so much for joining us
and of course for more coverage of all
the biggest and best games from e3 2016
head on over to GameSpot calm